the prime minister is under pressure
over the NHS and Strikes rishi's next
spokesperson has given an update to
journalists the first since the holidays
let's speak to our political
correspondent Liz Bates who's in Downing
Street
um Liz before we get to the NHS and
Strikes there's breaking news on
pre-departure Covert tests from people
flying in from China
yes well we did have some of this
information uh a few days ago but we've
really had confirmation of it today from
number 10 the issue is though I mean so
first of all I should tell you what it
is it is people traveling from China
into the UK will be asked to do a Kobe
test pre-departure and if they test
positive they will not be allowed on a
flight to the UK now we've known that
for a few days but we wanted a bit more
detail from number 10 number 10 given
that it's coming in January the 5th and
they certainly need to get on with it
because that's in two days time but we
haven't had confirmation yet on a few uh
details within this plan so what is
still unclear is connecting flights to
people traveling from China via another
country into the UK will they be asked
for these tests as well people from Hong
Kong we're still unsure about that
there's a slight anomaly as well when it
comes to people who arrive in the UK so
you get on a test you've had a
pre-departure negative cover test when
you arrive in the UK you are then asked
if you would like to do a Kobe test and
only a small sample of people will be
asked to do that and they can refuse to
do that the government says this is all
part of a plan that is about being
sensible and cautious and really this is
just about the lack of data coming out
of China not any real risks of any new
variants of concern so that is what we
currently know about
that issue of covid testing but when it
comes to NHS pressures obviously the
prime minister is is really been asked a
lot of questions about that and number
10 because we've had so many stories
about these terrible waiting times and
people being treated in hospital
corridors well what the government is
saying today is first of all that this
is due to the covid backlog they were
always expecting this to be a difficult
winter the first week of January is
always very difficult as well what's
quite interesting about this though is
the prime minister
certainly seems to be almost staying
away from this issue we understand first
of all this week There's no
um public events in the diary he's not
going to be visiting a hospital despite
the pressures on staff and on patients
we haven't had anything uh
publicly confirmed that the health
secretary is doing anything this week
either so maybe slightly surprising I
think the general feeling as well is
that number 10 and the Department of
Health may be taking the approach of
weighting these pressures out if you
like there's no expectation of any more
big announcements on funding they will
certainly go ahead with previous funding
announcements and they want to see
reform of course and they're very
thankful to all the staff they say
working through these winter pressures
but apart from that we're not expecting
any big announcements and it seems like
the Prime Minister certainly is going to
be staying indoors this week when he's
working at number 10.
okay Liz thank you